Jane Foster's wielding the magical hammer
Mjolnir, but she's also sporting some impressive arm muscles.
Are these guns connected to Mjolnir's return?
And how did Jane get her newly-jacked hands
on Thor's old hammer anyway?
Warning: spoilers ahead for "Thor: Love and
Thunder!"
Directed by Taika Waititi, "Thor: Love and
Thunder" has finally hit theaters, complete
with a brand new villain, numerous references
to mythology, and some screaming goats.
The narrative also reintroduces viewers to
Dr. Jane Foster whose presence is instrumental
in helping Thor and King Valkyrie battle against
an evil that threatens the future of New Asgard.
Ever since the first trailer dropped, fans
have been clamoring to find out what leads
the astrophysicist to become Mighty Thor and
how she came to possess Thor's old hammer.
At this point in the franchise, Mjolnir is
practically a character all its own.
The hammer's resurrection brings about a host
of changes, significantly influencing Thor's
journey to self-discovery.
After years of letting us wonder, "Thor: Love
and Thunder" finally explains why Thor and
Jane went their separate ways.
For an astrophysicist and the God of thunder,
the pair managed to build a strong foundation
for a future together.
Everything was good for a while, but the differences
in their lives eventually drove a wedge between them.
As it turns out, it's not easy building a
life with someone who's always running off
to face intergalactic threats.
Thor couldn't cope with his fear of losing
her, so he embraced the growing distance in
their relationship.
In the end, it was Jane who pulled the plug
on their romance, even if Thor has trouble
admitting it.
"Sorry to hear that Jane dumped you."
"She didn't dump me.
I dumped her.
It was a mutual dumping."
Following the events of "Avengers: Endgame,"
Thor is back to his old self with the help
of a strict workout regime and some quality
time with the Guardians of the Galaxy.
He hasn't seen Jane in years, but that's about
to change.
Jane's life has changed dramatically since
viewers last saw her in "Thor: The Dark World."
In Thor's absence, she's had plenty of time
to focus on her career.
Unfortunately, Jane discovers that she has
stage 4 cancer and her prognosis isn't looking good.
Although Darcy and Dr. Selvig have attempted
to convince her to save her energy, Jane has
been tirelessly working to find a way to cure
herself.
Reaching the end of her rope, Jane finds herself
drawn to tales from Norse mythology.
Although Thor and the other Asgardians aren't
immortal, a fact cemented by Loki's death
at the hands of Thanos, they don't fall victim
to the same frailties that affect humans.
Their magic grants them a certain level of
invulnerability, including super strength
and good health.
These aspects of godliness intrigue Jane,
but there's more to it than that.
Thor's hammer Mjolnir has always been a conduit
for this power and it calls out to Jane.
Flashbacks demonstrate that this is no accident.
As their relationship dwindled, Thor asked
Mjolnir to watch over Jane, a magical request
that has remained intact.
Even after all these years, Thor and Jane
are still connected, whether they know it or not.
In a last-ditch effort to cure her cancer,
Jane travels to New Asgard, which has become
a major tourist attraction.
After being destroyed by Hela in "Thor: Ragnarok,"
the broken pieces of Mjolnir are on display
in a glass case.
Since its destruction, everyone has assumed
that Mjolnir was beyond repair.
For the relocated Asgardians, the shattered
relic reminds them of where they came from
and all they've faced since the decimation
of their home world.
For sightseers, it's the physical embodiment
of one of Earth's mightiest heroes.
For Jane, it's her last hope for survival,
a doorway to a life where her illness is a
thing of the past.
All this time, Mjolnir was waiting for Jane
and she is more than worthy.
As promised, Mjolnir grants Jane the powers
of a god, resulting in the effortlessly cool,
muscled-up version of the character fans have
seen in trailers.
Unfortunately, wielding the hammer isn't enough
to save Jane, who dies helping Thor defeat
Gor the God Butcher.
Her sacrifice has a profound effect on Thor,
who is finally able to accept his past and
look towards a brighter future, Mjolnir in
hand.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.